>> Did you know that no two countries with a McDonald's, they've never gone to
war with each other? Did you know that? >> No.
>> No, I didn't know that. , >> Yeah, because everyone's way too lazy after they
get fat. >> China and the US haven't gone to war because there's a McDonald's in
China and then there's a McDonald's here. >> Really? No I didn't know that. >>
Two countries?
>> Yeah, did you know? >> No, I didn't know that. >> Wouldn't surprise me. >> Is
that really true? >> It's true.
>> Nobody had heard of the golden arches theory of conflict prevention before,
but I put them on the spot and asked them for a possible explanation. Why do you
think that is? >> Because that good food, tastes good. >> Globalization of the
economy. >> Once you have a McDonald's in your country, your motivation just
goes way down. >> To have a McDonald's you've reached a certain status, I guess.
, And that makes you more first world. I don't know.
>> Maybe countries that bring in McDonald's accept Americans a little more
freely. >> I don't know.
>> This correlation between McDonald's and peace can only lead to some
interesting policy conclusions. So I asked another question. >> So do you think
that if every country in the world had a McDonald's, there'd be world peace? >>
Absolutely not.
>> I don't think so because there's different, different, different ways that
everybody think. I wish everybody agreed to do it, but I don't think so. >> I'm
skeptical that it's true, actually. >> It's called the golden arches theory of
conflict resolution. >> Okay.
>> Correlation does not mean causation, so. >> Words of wisdom. >>, >> That
would be nice wouldn't it? >> Guess I'd go to McDonald's to get that Big Mac,
that smile on your face. You don't have to about anything. >> Mcdonald's
originated here, right? So, I mean , I just don't think it's in their best
interest to be putting up McDonalds's in places that they're at war with. >> I
mean, that, the, it stretched too far. There's way to correlate that data. >> I
think there probably is something more driving the conflict than not having a
McDonald's.